the jurogan experience it's a very
you know it's it's a very hard path and
and you know one of the
happiest place for me to go and the
saddest place to go
it's the gym when i go train to the gym
it's the happiest place for me to go
because i can practice the sport that i
love because i love training you know i
love the science of fighting
and it's very sad too because after
training there's always some
guys that come to me to because they
seek some advice
and i always give them advice regarding
fighting but
a lot of them my advice for them would
be hey bro
you know you should hang off you hang up
your gloves and find a real job you know
because
some of them because i i've seen this
movie and it's not a good ending my
friend like like go find but if i tell
them the truth
they'll get mad at you they get mad at
me because i'll be like oh yeah
you know what i mean like right you're
jealous yeah he's jealous you know he's
arrogant and stuff you know but
that's the thing i tell my real friends
that when it's time to hang up the
gloves i tell them the truth i said
listen
and i said to them like i said listen
man
what's good for you now you know you
know you you know it's a little bit like
in um
the movie uh uh with uh bruce willis you
know uh
uh quentin tarantino you know oh pop
fiction
fiction you know if you if you would if
you would have made it you would have
made it before you know
when he made that speech you know it's a
little bit the same thing but it's
it's i love that monologues it's amazing
but it's the truth
a lot of people should relate to this
but it's unfortunate well the reason why
champions are so exceptional it's
because it's so hard to become a
champion it's so rare
all the stars have to align you have to
have mental prowess
physical prowess you have to have great
coaching
you have to have so many different
factors have to come together and also
fortune i mean your guy has been through
some surgeries yes and we all know guys
who
they get injured and they can never even
train again it happens
it's unusual but it can happen and we're
dealing with this
this giant hurricane of possibilities
for someone to boom come out of that and
be a george saint pierre
or be a khabib nurmagomedov or a jon
jones or someone who's exceptional
it's so rare so when someone's kid comes
up to you and says i'm going to be the
next world champion you're like
the possibility that the odds of failure
are so they're so
so high they're so high that's the thing
it's it's i believe it's you need to
have a certain
predisposition yeah i met in my
life incredible mentors that had a
huge influence on me they they taught me
like great life lessons techniques and
it's
incredible like if i would not have had
that
those those guys who influenced me i
would never have been where i am right
now and plus on top of that you know
i got i worked really hard and i was
lucky you know like the star were all
aligned but you need all that
and you need the great coaching is so
important too
there's so many guys that are really
talented but they they they have meat
head coaches
and their coaches train them the wrong
way so they spar full blast in the gym
and then they go out and they
they lose and then they have their coach
has them sparring a couple weeks after
they get knocked
out and that kind of [ __ ] and and they
don't have the technical prowess their
technical
proficiency to teach a child or a kid or
an athlete right
you can get unlucky you know i believe
the best way to improve it's when it's
playful
i've seen so many guys drew i can't say
names but
it's crazy how many guys i've seen that
left their career in the gyms
yeah because they expire too hard every
sparring for them it's
it's about winning the round yeah it's
about life or death
you cannot improve like this you need to
be playful
of course when you're in training camp
and your fight is coming up you need to
somehow trying to recreate that
environment of
discomfort that stress
but when you're outside of that
preparation preparation zone you need
you need to be playful because that's
when you you improve when it's playful
when it's like a game you know because
you will be more prone to trying new
things
and and by trying new things you'll
you'll adapt you'll be like oh this one
works this one
doesn't work but the one that works i
keep it in my back pocket you know and
it makes you grow that's our problems
you know i've seen
like very often i see guys like sparring
they they
they lose a lot of brain cells it's
terrible it's terrible
and i'm well i'm a former world champion
you know like when i spar with
with guys very often they are nervous so
they become all stiff and when they hit
they hit so hard i tell them i'm like
you don't get ready you don't have any
fight coming up soon like just have fun
but relax i tell them
relax and they very often they they
relax
you know some will try to make you know
so i have to answer back
i have to but but very often they relax
and
and and they're surprised that because
it's so so much of an egotistic
sport you know like we have this
mentality that oh if the guy tells you
to relax because he's scared you know
right
it's so stupid you know but it's that's
how if you want to improve you need to
it needs to be
playful and and in everything you know
you
we say oh you when i say inspiring
when i when i'm about to spar with
someone i never sparred before
i that's what i do i tell him i say hey
would you like to play a little bit i
don't use the word sparring
because sparring is like aggression and
i tell him as hey
would you like to play a little bit
there then we touch glove and we play
and and i never go hard i always start
very very slow and if i see that
he's going toward i tell him i say
please go go more
more easy and of course if he's getting
ready for a fight it's
different it's a different situations
but you know that's how it is you know
when you need
you shouldn't be afraid to tell your
training partner hey
please like put it like slow down a
notch you know like
like when you see guys trying to throw a
head kick to knock each other
out you know in boxing sparring it's
different because we
we have big gloves big head gear you
know they can't go hard i mean
even if it's not good because it's
repeatedly blows
repetition to with the blows of the head
but
in mma with the kicks it's the damage is
basically like a baseball bat hitting
your head you can't do that
it's it's crazy man the thais have it
right right
that's right that's right because they
have so many fights
they have so many fights that and also
when you fight someone
when i fight someone it happens very
often in my career like
when i fight someone you have a
connection with the guy you fight a lot
of things happen here
and real fighter will know that what i'm
talking about the connection that we
have because you look at each other
and these this connection you cannot see
it when you watch the fight on tv
but very often in most of my fight
when i went to decision i could see the
guy break
breaking folding like he's letting me
know that
he doesn't fight to win anymore he's
fighting to not lose
and like i said earlier it's not up to
me trying to
trying to push the pace trying to to
finish him and
increasing my risk of getting cut by a
counter punch and getting knocked out
you know it's up to him to take the risk
you know because he's losing the fight
and the idea in this game you want to
save yourself for another day i mean
it's sad to say for the family this is
the truth
if you win and that's what you're doing
is good you win
you're winning the fight you know you're
going to get paid the the same amount of
money of course if you have like an
highlight wheel
something like that it could increase
your pay but but in terms of
your career i believe you should see
your career as a marathon not as a
sprint
so you you kind of save yourself and a
lot of time i fought guys
i could see in their face that oh he
doesn't want to be there anymore like i
know i'm winning the fight before even
the fight is over
they get desperate of course they're
gonna throw a haymaker or something but
i know they're not gonna take any risk
because they
they're they're hurt they're they lost
already they know that i'm better than
them
and that's when i know i get the fight
and i know that i'm just need to be on
cruise control i can win
if they don't like it's hard to to
finish someone
who doesn't fight to win anymore right
you see very often
champions in in mma
have a very dominate dominant career in
the beginning
you know they finish a lot of their
opponent but after a while it become
it kind of peak because all the entire
ufc roaster is studying you and they
figure you out
maybe they didn't figure you out how to
beat you but they figure
out how to kind of survive and and hang
in there with you
jon jones is a good example of that
right everybody myself same thing like
every like a lot of guy anderson silva
the the the all the the champions that's
what happened
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience